hey youtubers is charlie and there's one
more week until dr. who gets here
congratulations to anyone that's made it
to the world tour so far they're
actually headed to New York next I live
in Los Angeles so I will not be able to
get arrested trying to tackle Peter
Capaldi with hugs but if any of you want
to try just send me pictures before you
get arrested they just released a proper
trailer for episode 1 deep breath so
this video is going to be a breakdown of
the new things in that and we've also
learned the titles from all the regular
episodes there are 12 the 13th is a
Christmas special but we don't know
anything about that yet if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Doctor Who videos I even do a
weekly doctor who give away all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
let's take a deep breath and get started
a lot of this is all familiar footage
and because it jumps around in the
episode I'm just gonna reorganize things
a little bit as I talk about them just
so it's a little more linear so here we
go starting with the dinosaurs in London
I know some of you weren't really taken
with dinosaurs on a spaceship but as
much as the t-rex is comedy its sheer
size makes you think less of tri ki and
more Jurassic Park fun fact though in
the comics Gallifrey Skaro and Montes
all had their own breeds of dinosaur the
Gallifreyan ones were called
gigantosaurus the Skaro ones were just
Triceratops with one big horn and the
modest ones were pretty much like Earth
I'm source since montez's or two twin
planet the Montes even converted some of
their dinosaurs to write his mouths I
know that sounds a little bit weird but
robot dinosaurs sounds pretty cool my
head I don't think that this dinosaurs
connected to any of the big villains the
season I think it's just there to
introduce Capaldi with some Flair but
the doctor does speak dinosaur and i'm
not talking about sigh lorien he can
speak to big dinosaurs like the t-rex i
don't know if they'll actually show this
in the episode is just a funny fact so
here's the doctor out of Matt Smith's
costume but not yet in his new one this
episode's the transition from Smith to
Capaldi so naturally he has to get into
his new outfit through the course of the
episode in the promo pics we've seen in
the other trailer footage he's wearing a
couple different outfits there's the
Victorian outfit there's the kind of
homeless person and shabby looking
outfit they're all different from what
the final costume is going to be this is
the official costume presumably he'll be
in it by the end of the first episode
Smith changed his appearance a few times
during the Christmas special so the
doctor has had a few episodes where he
has several different outfits in the
same episode this is a really
interesting meta thing going on with the
outfits between matt smith and
capaldi you have the anachronistic Matt
Smith costume young man in very old
timey clothes that are Victorian and now
here we're back in Victorian times when
those clothes will be completely normal
cut to old man appropriately dressed in
old man's Victorian clothes obviously
Capaldi's final out that is in Victorian
but the outfits that he wears in this
episode are largely Victoria just
because they're hand-me-downs from the
time all the interview coats that I've
been saying from the world tour have
been about how no-nonsense Capaldi is
going to be most of the interviews sound
like they're meant for people who have
never seen Doctor Who because I feel
like anyone who watched the 50th
anniversary and saw the clip of his eyes
knew exactly what kind of personality he
was gonna have you can let me know if
you agree but whenever I saw his eyes
for the first time I just thought he was
going to be like the badass doctor this
montage sets up the action of the
episode then dealing with the dinosaur
the mysterious robot man and the fact
that the doctors still delirious from
regeneration if he had trouble
understanding Peter Capaldi through his
Scottish accent especially when he's
speaking very fast he says the question
is have there been any similar murders
there was a rumor early on in production
that Jack the Ripper was going to be
involved in the episode I don't think
that's the case I think they're just
talking about the robot man in this next
scene Foster said she actually killed an
eight Jack the Ripper during good man
goes to war that was series 6 episode 7
so i'm pretty sure that it's not him
that made that big explosion and i do
like the foster implies that no matter
how addled the doctors mind is from
regeneration he automatically hones in
on trouble like a bloodhound so then it
actually looks like we're going to get
another badass vostra and Jenny battle
there was a really good wondering
crimson horrid that was series 7 episode
12 they had a really nice fight and then
we get the really big payoff scene I
love that they gave Clara the doctors
line you've redecorated most people
probably remember this from the 50th
anniversary last year but the second
doctor originated it the first time he
said it was during the 3dr special when
he saw the third doctors TARDIS and then
again in the five doctors special inside
the unit headquarters to Brigadier
lethbridge-stewart then Matt Smith said
it to Craig whenever he saw his house in
closing time series 6 episode 12 and
then most recently David Tennant when he
saw Matt Smith's TARDIS in the 50th
anniversary I think Clara is mostly
reverencing the bookshelves because the
TARDIS structure is essentially the same
Steven Moffat just kind of redecorated a
little bit for Capaldi I think that Matt
Smith did have bookshelves and paintings
at one point inside the control room
before he met Clara but after he
redesigned his TARDIS there were also
bookshelves inside the seventh doctors
TARDIS which was actually more Victorian
looking so suppose you consider that a
bit of an easter egg since we are in
Victorian times in this episode I guess
we'll find out eventually if the
bookshelves are going to stick but the
footage in the trailer that we saw the
first couple promos from the first
couple of episodes so it's possible I
can't wait to get the full on look
inside so we'll see what else has
changed I think the Capaldi's final
smile here is just him acknowledging the
humor of her taking what should be his
line and so now here are the titles of
each of the twelve episodes during the
main series ok so remember deep breath
officially premieres on television
saturday the 23rd i think if you're
watching on BBC one it's seven or eight
p.m. gmt but if you do have access to
BBC america they're also premiering john
sims new series intruders right after
doctor who it's going to be like orphan
black season one last year where the air
Doctor Who first and then intruders
right after for the entire season I'm
not planning on doing any videos for
intruders but I will be watching it so
you guys should check it out this week
because the official Doctor Who team
made a very special request that I do a
classic who video i'll be posting 14
episodes that you should check out
before series 8 premieres it's ok even
if you've never watched classic who or
the new series episode 1 of series 8 is
designed to explain all the basics
anyway so do not feel weird about
jumping on if you're totally new to the
show and all of course be doing a ton of
bonus videos what it's going to be is
i'll be doing a bonus video before
episodes premiere then i'll do my
regular episode video where I'll do
giveaways and then I'll do my Q&A video
after the episode the giveaways will
always start in the episode review just
like I did for Game of Thrones and I'll
name winners in the q and A's I am
posting a QA for this video tonight so
if you do want enter the giveaway just
make sure that your subscriber and leave
a comment on this video there'll only be
one winner per week but sometimes I do
double the giveaway so I might randomly
just pick two people to win right now
you can click here to get that Q&A video
all the annotation as soon as I post it
and click here to learn all about Peter
Capaldi coming back in series 9 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight high fives
you